it's time for the launching promised own
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought show you
every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
what's company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene chrono scope mister william
bradford huie editor of the american
mercury and mr. James HR Cromwell former
United States minister to Canada our
distinguished guest for this evening is
the Honorable Joseph R Farrington
delegate to Congress from the territory
of Hawaii the opinions expressed are
necessarily those of the speaker's mr.
Farrington about two million Americans I
believe traveled through Hawaii during
the second war and met most of our
viewers tonight hope to go to Hawaii at
some time during their lifetime so it's
a great pleasure to have you with us
tonight sir now what word can you give
all of our viewers who have been to
Hawaii and those who do want to go how
is business generally in the islands now
business in Hawaii is very good are you
prospering on a defense economy there
now the expenditures for national
defense since the outbreak of the Korean
War have been increased substantially
and we have prospered as a result of
that and i'd like to say also for
particularly for the benefit of those
who have been to hawaii that there's
been a heavy increase in tourist travel
and that conditions there are much more
attractive for the tourists now than
they were of course during the war now
is the is the military as
all your bread and butter in Hawaii it's
still your number one source of income I
said well it's a source of largest
income at the present time although we
don't regard it as the base of our
economy by any means and where it is a
sugar and pineapple interest how do they
rank behind him of any basic industry of
Hawaii is the raising of sugar cane we
produce about a million tons of raw
sugar a year some proximately 25% of the
sugar produced under the American flag
the next product is pineapples and we
produce about 85 to 90 percent of all
the pineapples consumed by the people of
this country the third is the tourist
industry and if you're any new hotels
out there belt since yes we have we have
a several very fine new hotels a one in
particular the surfrider is just in
front of the famous Waikiki Beach surf
have you a housing shortage out there at
the present time well we've had a
housing shortage as a matter of fact
since the beginning of the emergency
before World War two and it still exists
our bill extend your your labor troubles
out there have made a great many
headlines in the United States so you
still vexed with labor troubles is that
one of your difficulties now yes that's
very true but I don't think a much more
so than the rest of the country I'd like
to point out that in Hawaii organized
labor as such show wasn't established as
an effective economic force until after
World War Two and today with in respect
particularly to our basic industries
we're much in the same phase as coal was
way back in nineteen twelve as steel
wasn't about 1919 as automobiles were in
about nineteen thirty the
most militant of unions as was
established the labor movement in Hawaii
as an effective force and they still
maintain that leadership you think
they're more left-wing in Hawaii than
would be the case in the United States
what are speaking that's a that's true
of the of the largest and principal
union in Hawaii its international
longshoreman long sermons and where
Houseman's Union and it is regarded as
being among the principal left wing
unions of the country that's the one
that's under the leadership of mr.
bridges that's correct well is it true
to say that your your whole economy is
more or less at the mercy of mr. Harry
bridges well I don't contend that our
economy is at the mercy of Harry bridges
our economy is that the the is subject
to the geographical conditions that that
maintained in Hawaii we're isolated from
the coast by 2,400 miles of water and
unless the shipping lanes are maintained
open we just can't live and that means
that you're at the mercy of the shipping
unions well we're at the mercy of the
shipping unions are of an administration
that's unwilling to keep the ships
sailing and now while the shipping
unions have gained power over you sir
does that mean that your traditional big
five has lost economic power in Hawaii
and political power well for a long
period of time the big five who are
generally represented as the factors who
operate the sugar industry constitute of
the dominating economic implement they
were more or less Bostonians
New England people with a nod to big
five the the the basis of our political
social and economic life was established
by the missionaries who went to Hawaii
from Boston in 1820 and developed our
industry much in the pattern of the
American tradition so why has been
accused you know in articles that I've
read mystifying being somewhat of a
feudal state under the guidance of this
big five so-called is do you think
that's still true no I don't if it ever
was a feudalism it was a very benevolent
feudalism and very much in the American
pattern but i think that the
diversification of their strength and
power has taken has taken care of that
in the last of course the principal
aspiration of the why now is to become a
state isn't it that's correct and as far
as statehood is concerned you don't
expect it to be granted this year no I
doubt if the Senate will take action on
the statehood before it adjourns this
summer in their opposition to statehood
in Hawaii itself there is opposition to
statehood in Hawai but it comes from a
dwindling minority our viewers of course
have heard senators like senator Stennis
of Mississippi and others state why they
are opposed to statehood for why
principally because of dilution of the
Congress is that where most of the
Opposition in Congress comes from from
southern senators yes the principal and
the most serious opposition comes from
the senators from the South who want to
maintain the traditional position of the
south with respect to certain types of
legislation under the present rules of
the Senate which permit unlimited debate
they have what amounts to the power to
veto legislation to which they
very serious objections now what if
ardently mr. fountain I had one senator
tell me that he was opposed to statehood
for Hawaii because we might have an
oriental senator what do you think of
that is that a possibility and what do
you think of it if it is a possibility I
want to answer that by saying that no
one will represent Hawaiian Congress who
first of all is not an American citizen
and I don't think it is a proper to
raise any questions regarding their
ancestral background any more than it is
to do the same with the people of the
States what about loyalty to the United
States did you during the second war for
instance did you have any was disloyalty
a great problem in Hawaii no it was not
and on the contrary the record of Hawaii
of fully vindicated the confidence that
we had in the Americans of Oriental
ancestry I want to say in part with
further reference in your question mr.
Cromwell that that of course is within
the realm of possibility and the weight
of Hawaii would not offer any objection
to a man because of his race I think
that if someone came along who met the
requirements of the of such a position
that he would be selected when I lived
in Hawai before they wore encountered
what I thought was a very remarkable
situation there and that was in the
shape of these Japanese language schools
they still have those Japanese language
schools know the Japanese language
schools were discontinued following the
outbreak of World War World War two they
no longer exist that's right now you
were talking about the melting pot
aspects of a warrior so you've lived in
Hawaii most of your life that's correct
and it's rather dramatic I think this
all of these races that do live together
now is it true that they live together
successfully and that there is they
cohesion in the islands do you have a
more or less united people I feel very
definitely that we have an unusually
cohesive people one thing that
distinguishes people of Hawaii with
regards without regard to their racial
origin is their love for Hawaii which to
them is the United States they love the
country geographically and every other
way and are deeply devoted is a
communism a problem there yes communism
is a problem in Hawaii but I don't think
any more so than it is elsewhere I think
to compensate for that there's an
unusual alertness of the seriousness the
communism both as it presents itself
internationally and nationally Guzman
statehood would strengthen our defense
position in the islands I'm certain that
it would strengthen our defense position
because statehood historically has
stimulated the economic development of
every community or area to which it has
granted and it is also inspired the
people to a sense of their
responsibilities and two activities
American citizens that might not
otherwise be realized well mr.
Farrington as the principal spokesman
for Hawaii's aspirations I'm sure that
our audience is very much appreciated
hearing your views tonight and thank you
sir
the editorial board for this edition of
the lawn gene Cronus Koch was mister
william bradford huie and mr. James HR
Cromwell our distinguished guest was the
Honorable Joseph R Farrington delegate
to Congress from the territory of Hawaii